-Well,
if you weren't confused already,
you're about to see one band
play in two cities
at the same time.
Here with the song
"Black Summer"
from their highly anticipated
and critically acclaimed
new album "Unlimited Love,"
Red Hot Chili Peppers!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ A lazy rain am I ♪
♪ The skies refuse to cry ♪
♪ Cremation takes its piece
of your supply ♪
♪♪
♪ The night
is dressed like noon ♪
♪ A sailor spoke too soon ♪
♪♪
♪ And China's
on the dark side of the Moon ♪
♪♪
♪ Platypus are a few ♪
♪ The secret life of roo ♪
♪ A personality I never knew ♪
♪♪
♪ My Greta weighs a ton ♪
♪ The archers on the run ♪
♪ And no one stands alone
behind the sun ♪
♪♪
♪ It's been a long time
since I made a new friend ♪
♪ Waitin' on another
black summer to end ♪
♪ It's been a long time
and you never know when ♪
♪ Waitin' on another
black summer to end ♪
♪♪
♪ Crack the flaming whip ♪
♪ A-sailing on a censorship ♪
♪ Riding on a headless horse
to make the trip ♪
♪♪
♪ Been a long time
since I made a new friend ♪
♪ Waitin' on another
black summer to end ♪
♪ It's been a long time
and you never know when ♪
♪ Waitin' on another
black summer to end ♪
♪♪
♪ I been waitin',
I been waitin' ♪
♪ Waitin' on another
black summer to end ♪
♪ I been waitin',
I been waitin' ♪
♪ Waitin on another
black summer to end ♪
♪ I been waitin',
I been waitin ♪
♪ Waitin on another
black summer to end ♪
♪♪
[ Finale plays ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Music ends ]
[ Cheers and applause continue ]